what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like Marvel Studios is
embracing special presentations we've
already gotten werewolf by night there's
a report that states we are getting a
Silver Surfer special presentation
yesterday we heard that we could be
getting a Mephisto special and today we
have a report stating we are getting a
Sentry special presentation that is
going to film alongside the Thunderbolts
and unfortunately it does look like
Marvel Studios has officially delayed
Phase 5 and possibly even phase six of
the MCU but we're gonna break it down
and tell you everything you need to know
in this video let's start with the
Sentry special presentation report it
seems like there is sort of a theme
going on with Marvel Studios right now
and that is to shoot these special
presentations along with other shows or
movies that are currently being filmed
which does make a lot of sense and does
save quite a bit of time especially when
these characters that are getting the
special presentations are going to be in
these other movies or shows it just
makes for example yesterday it was
reported that Mephisto could be getting
a special presentation if you didn't see
our video on that be sure to check it
out but it's reportedly going to be
filming with Agatha coven of chaos
because Mephisto is reportedly going to
be in that movie so they are essentially
killing two birds with one stone again
very smart and it looks like they're
going to be doing that with Thunderbolts
and Sentry as well now if you haven't
heard it's pretty much confirmed by
everybody but Marvel Studios because
they have yet to comment on it but it's
pretty much confirmed that century is
indeed going to be in the Thunderbolts
movie and it looks like right now as far
as we're concerned Steven young is going
to be playing century and it looks like
Sentry is going to be a pretty big deal
in the MCU as it's reported that he is
going to get his own special
presentation this report is coming from
thecosmiccircus.com and they have a
pretty good track record when it comes
to Scoops they originally reported that
Marvel Studios was going to try to kind
of experiment more with special present
Asians to see how they go and so far
they've actually gone quite well
werewolf by night was a really big hit
and so was the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special and according to the
cosmic circus and other sources as well
there's a lot more special presentations
on the way and this is a good thing and
we'll talk about why it is in just a bit
but the cosmic circus has a report about
one of them that seems to be confirmed
of course will be about Century in their
report they state that on the old Marvel
Studios spoilers Reddit subpage R.I.P it
was reported on there that Sentry is
indeed going to be getting a special
presentation and it stated that this
would be the holiday special for this
year 2023 and that it's going to be shot
at the same time as the Thunderbolts but
now it seems like the cosmic circus can
confirm this stating in their article
what they heard and they say that their
sources also believe that a Sentry
project is in development and it is
expected to film alongside the
Thunderbolts movie so right now for 2023
if these recent reports are true we
should be getting a Mephisto Halloween
special this October followed up by a
century holiday special which is great
news if it's true because as of right
now we're only really expecting two
Disney Plus shows from Marvel Studios
this year and we're still not even
actually sure about that we know that no
matter what we should be getting secret
Invasion we've already gotten a full
trailer for it plus other footage and
although Marvel Studios hasn't given us
an official release date for it
expecting it by Spring this year however
unfortunately Loki season 2 is kind of
up in the air right now as well as the
rest of phase five it looks like Phase 5
could have been delayed by Marvel
Studios indefinitely which will in turn
most likely affect phase six however
there is a chance that if they kind of
cancel some projects or put them off
until after phase six phase six might
not be that delayed and it does kind of
seem like there are some projects that
can happen after A6 that probably won't
go into the overall story of Secret Wars
the reason that we believe that maybe
Loki isn't going to come this year as we
stated in a previous video instead of
Disney plus stating the release date for
Loki season 2 as summer of 2023 they
have now stated it as coming soon sadly
for the shows coming in Phase 5 they
have done this as well stating instead
of Phase 5 they have switched it to
coming soon now what's interesting here
is that some Phase 5 projects are going
to be very important for the overall
story arc of Secret Wars and some not so
much however the ones that don't really
affect Secret Wars do affect other
Disney plus projects that will go on to
affect Secret Wars for example the echo
Series this probably won't really affect
Secret Wars or tie into it very much if
not at all however Daredevil most likely
will be in secret Wars and Daredevil is
going to be in the Echo Series so is
Kingpin and story is probably rather
important for the Daredevil series it
means you can't just scrap the echo
series or push it off until after phase
six because even though it might not
have much to do with Secret Wars
Daredevil most likely will in the Echo
story affects Daredevil this is kind of
a good sign though because this means
that most likely Marvel Studios won't
cancel any of the upcoming projects at
least maybe none that they've already
announced
5 this would be the echo series which
was originally supposed to come out
before Loki season 2. ironheart Agatha
coven of chaos and Daredevil born again
and the reason that I don't mention Loki
is because it is way too of an important
show that connects to not only King but
Secret Wars in its entirety to cancel or
to move back by too much they are 100
never canceling the show however it
might be delayed by a few months again
here's the thing the ironheart series is
supposed to have the hood as the villain
and he is supposed to be directly
connected to Mephisto who is rumored to
be making a cameo in ironheart well
right now mephista was rumored to also
be the villain of Agatha coven of chaos
so if he's going to make his appearance
and it's going to be important in Iron
Heart then you can't push ironheart
after coven of chaos it needs to come
before it for it all to sync up and make
sense and again this is a good thing
because this means that shows most
likely won't be canceled however it is
still definitely possible Marvel Studios
could do everything but what another
option for Marvel Studios could be which
they are clearly considering at this
point in time is to turn some Disney
Plus shows into Disney plus specials
they're not against this because we've
already seen it with armor Wars although
armor Wars wasn't turned into a Disney
plus special it did go from a Disney
Plus show into a movie and now that
Marvel Studios is President Kevin feige
and Disney CEO Bob Iger have come out
and stated that from here on out they
are indeed going to be focusing quality
over quantity this option does make
sense especially if you consider their
current strategy filming Disney plus
specials with the actual shows or movies
that go along with them this would save
time that way nothing has to be rushed
the visual effects artists don't have to
be rushed they don't have to be worked
overtime and they can actually focus on
the quality some insiders have
speculated not confirmed but speculated
that this could push Marvel Studios back
with Phase 5 and phase six two years or
so and yes that is a bummer however if
it is indeed going to make all of the
projects both shows special
presentations and movies better I'm sure
most fans would agree that that's what
they want good quality content it does
kind of seem like Marvel Studios is
going back to what they did before with
phase one through three release two to
three really great movies a year and now
we can add great Disney plus projects
and special presentations as well this
would be a really good strategy I think
for Marvel Studios to kind of revert
back to instead of doing five Disney
Plus shows a year and four movies a year
scaled down a little bit and focus on
quality over quantity which is what they
said they are doing so I think the
future of Marvel Studios is very bright
and I'm really curious to see who gets a
special presentation let us know what
you think about all of this and let us
know who you would like to see get a
Disney plus special leave your thoughts
in the comments down below please don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all the
latest MCU news and of course you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
hey